[Music]
so
the hearing
on the 2000
2022 representation review arrangements
um
so the reporters and
under hearings in your diligent for
those that
are looking for where that is based
i've got an apology just to remind
everyone that we are on live stream
audio this afternoon
uh and we i have apologies from uh
councillor blacky
and councillor stewart
some are prepared to move move to
council brian secretary councillor
williams
i'll put the apologies
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear they're carried
um just we are remember the public are
here we are required to wear our face
masks uh
council award has an exemption um for uh
not wearing one so just to
advise that any conflicts of interest
none to be declared so we come firstly
to the hearing of submissions the
representation review and we have um
with us rhonda mather ronda i wonder if
you could come forward
it's good to see you here
welcome to our meeting um so up to 10
minutes and there may be some questions
that come from colleagues so
thank you for your time
thank you lovely to be here in this
lovely new room you've got going on it
looks great
uh okay so i'm not going to keep you
terribly long
i just want to highlight one particular
thing
so we've come a long way since the
controversial 2015 review and i learned
a lot about local government
representation representation at that
time and that's largely why i care
enough to be sitting here today
it won't come as news to you that there
are four councillors covering the
kaiapoi wood in ward
i'm here to emphasise the need to have a
councillor specifically representing the
woody and sifton community board area
around the council table
i know all councillors are expected to
represent all areas
i also know that most councillors know
their own area best
while the current system allows for a
resident of the wood in sifton area to
be elected as a councillor
their chances of becoming elected are
slim unless they have a high profile in
the kaiapoi area
population
population figures used in the current
representation review show that the
total population for the kaiapoi woody
ward is 24 900. that being 15 650 for
the kaiapoi to a hilly community board
area and
9240 for the wood in sifton community
board area that becomes something of an
imbalance when a candidate from the
wooden seven area has to compete for
votes against people in and around the
more highly populated kaiboy area
i've sat on a variety of council sorry
set in on a variety of council and board
meetings over the past six years or so
and have regularly been shocked to hear
how little some councillors know about
the area they represent
and i don't mean that as an insult or a
generalization
it's an observation that i find
disturbing and as a voter leaves me
feeling under-represented around the
council table at times
obviously there are no guarantees
regardless of where the candidate comes
from or the area they have been elected
to represent
as with all occupations there will be
varying degrees of how effective and
involved councillors are
my point is that as a resident of the
pegasus woodland area i want my vote to
go to a local resident who i know is
knowledgeable and involved when it comes
to local matters
i want my vote to count
and that's all i've got to say today so
thank you and happy to take any
questions
thanks rhonda um very clear submission
uh any questions
counselor
so rhonda what relief are you seeking in
your submission what do you want to have
happen
uh
well to be honest it's not something i'm
really expecting is going to be able to
happen this time around i'm kind of
giving a heads up for um in the future
you can waive your magic wand to make it
happen this time be great but i'm
seeking
for a counsellor who specifically is
elected for the woody and sefton board
area
so you're looking at the subdivision and
wanting one representative there and
three
i would imagine you're not going to go
two and two from a population point of
view so
yes
thank you kels williams
yeah do you
ask in your submission you've said that
councils do um
the whole of waimakariri is that not the
role to represent your area of a
community board and pass that on to one
of the councils that and that's the
reason
why community boards were set up i
understand for the the area community
and that should be represented in that
area and then passed on to a councillor
or are you an indicating you should get
rid of the community boards
and just have a um a counsellor for the
area no nice triple absolutely not
advocating to get rid of anybody's
community board
but what i'm saying is and i'm sure you
will know that having your bum around
this table as more as a more effective
voice
to be able to pass on
what the community board or someone else
might have told you or just to be able
to represent your community full stop
it's far more effective to have that
person around this table
but i'm not in any way saying we don't
need community boards or trying to
listen
the effect of their role they do a great
job in my opinion all of them
thank you further questions
well thank you ronda for your time we
appreciate your reflections and they
will be taken into account as when we
come to deliberate uh further in the
piece so thank you thank you very much
always appreciate the opportunity to
have my we say and i'm just going to sit
over here and have a listen now
thanks rhonda
all right so we now come to the report
item 4
which is
contained within the
hearing report so
sarah
thank you mr mayor
the report i will take has read
clearly spells out where we
have got to at this point in time
and a more full report will come to the
council on the 2nd of november
we had six weeks of consultation um for
the representation review including a
period when the three waters
consultation was
out so we had additional
foot traffic
through the web pages
and however we do acknowledge that it is
a relatively low number of submissions
with 15 being received
these submissions do generally reflect
the evidence and conversations from
earlier in the year with taking a
pragmatic approach to the electoral
arrangements for the october 22 election
with the majority supporting the quote
status quo
regarding the feedback suggesting
abolishing of subdivisions as you're
aware these effectively aid
representation
helping avoid dominance of urban areas
particularly for our rural areas
to the to the election point in time and
then as soon as the election is actually
over
that subdivision line effectively
is erased as all members of a community
board are consulting on all of the
issues that are put before them
so i have nothing further to
add at this time and welcome any
questions
thank you thanks sarah any questions
all right we've got a series of oh i'm
sorry when do you pardon me
just um a clarification please sarah
um
with this at the moment and there's no
changing
is there likely
that you that you could have another one
another
election next next time after the
elections can you re-look at your
representation review
legally we have to do a review every six
years but you can do it every three
we will be strongly recommending to the
incoming council
that in
february 23
we look at doing another representation
review
by then we will have
potentially
better census data
better growth data on actual people and
houses in our high growth areas
and also we will have a better direction
of the
local government reforms coming and how
that may impact
on any future elections
so this
primarily is looking at next year's
elections
with decisions confirmed by the local
government commission by april of next
year
and then we'll have a review and see
where we need to go for the 2025
elections
thank you you've answered my questions
thank you
uh cousin
uh thank you sarah how does the recent
government decision to potentially
extend our term by up to one year
affect your
representation review in 2023
certainly doesn't make any impact at
this stage it is only a discussion with
the government
there have been waves over the years of
three terms four terms
four year terms
nothing's legislated yet there's a lot
of conversation to occur
so we'll cross that bridge once we
actually know what
legislation
involves at that time
any further questions so
do we need to commit to a
review now no in 2023 or can that be a
decision that is a decision of the new
council
this council is only working through
next year's election arrangements
okay no further any further questions so
we've got a series of recommendations as
some are prepared to move
uh moved by councillor williams seconded
by
deputy mayor atkinson
do you wish to speak council williams
well i think um we've had a wee bit of
talk of discussions about um
at everything and um we've had no
i think but the number of submissions we
had
most people think it's um
working
reasonably well so
thank you for
sorting okay
thank you council deputy american
thank you mr mayor i just i just think
that um
given another three years we will be a
much better position to uh
to either
move stay the same or do whatever it may
be again but i don't three years is not
a long period so um i i think that um
this is the sensible
decision for now and and basically it is
a bit of a holding pattern until such
time as we
as we um
learn more about what is or not
happening about local government the
reforms that we have in front of us
and uh the numbers of the census which
is extremely important i mean they
haven't uh they haven't been reliable
for some time so to actually
have
have those numbers
100 would be would be much better i mean
i think just about all of us even at the
um
even at the review panel have uh
grappled with some of the numbers that
you actually totally know in your mind
and the ones that are put before us but
the census numbers are what we need to
uh need to work off
thank you councilman
is um i have quite a lot of sympathy for
the submitter mrs maitha because
the fact that in the last representation
review six years ago
wooden ashley was the one that
disappeared
which was my former award and since that
time i do feel that woody pegasus area
has lacked local knowledge around the
council table
however the boundaries change all the
time and quite often they change and the
counselor who's living in that world
ends up outside that wood um or they
move woods such as i did living in cast
and then still representing wood in
ashley so unfortunately it is a reality
that we are councillors at large and we
do need to make sure that we're in touch
with every single community
it does seem a little bit but now that
we're getting so much growth in that
eastern area particularly with
ravenswood subdivision coming on stream
it's going to get to the point where
what in pegasus is actually going to
have more population than the oxford or
hoka ward
potentially and so therefore for them
not to have a single representative does
seem a little bit unfair however as
everyone has stated we're in a bit of a
state of flux at the moment the die was
cast in the last representation review
which is when this prep should have been
addressed but the decision was to make
it go made to go to three wards and i
think to change it now would be a bit
premature
as other speakers have stated
i do encourage obviously um those in the
kai boi would to kaiboy william wood to
make sure that they are completely in
touch with their community board members
because those are your eyes and ears for
people um i'm in the ranger ashley and i
don't know what's going on in okuku so
therefore i use my community board to be
eyes and ears for me in that area to
make sure that i'm fully in touch with
my ward area
so
under that basis i do think that there
was not much else we could do given the
current situation but the growth in
population in the woody and pegasus area
is going to need to say necessitate some
change probably in the next review
um i'm just going to i'd like to speak
just to say that i support the
recommendation that's here
can i firstly start by acknowledging
both sarah and emma and i realise that
this will come back to a
further council meeting but sarah and
emma have done an excellent job
in helping us through this exercise
it was clear when we were going through
it that um really perhaps at this point
like a
good sense this information and that
there had been a very thorough review
done last time that it was going to be
probably just
um some minor changes that were required
and we have done those
and as well that has been recommended
uh there i
i understand what um
uh submitter
mentioned before that's not really a
position i'm prepared to look at right
at the moment i certainly understand the
points that are made but i think that's
something for another matter
i i know from this table how well
you all advocate uh for your communities
and how well connected you are
um and so i i know what council barnett
just said just then but i
know that the members that particularly
that represent those wards that were
mentioned certainly do do their very
best
here at this table so i just want to
make that clear community boards are a
very important function and this
exercise and one that
i try to get to as many board meetings
as i can and keep in touch with what's
going on we have regular meetings with
the board chairs and the deputy chairs
and we have regular briefings
which members attend and
i do try and encourage where we have big
issues um not just for the council but
in board areas that we do have joint
briefings where it concerns those bored
areas because
it's actually i'd rather have a joint
conversation together at times because
we actually do get some reflections
which are helpful to our considerations
so
i just want to say that i
understand the points that have been
made but i would just like to
acknowledge that we do have a very well
functioning democracy here and i think
that goes back to
what council williams said at the start
that we haven't had a large number but
large numbers don't necessarily mean
um that it's a representation either
it's actually the quality of the points
that are made and i think there's been
some good quality points
that have been put forth and that's
probably a matter that should be
considered by the next council i'm
presently
based on what i've read and what i
understand of submissions as well
the present arrangements are serving us
well with those minor changes but
that'll be a matter that we will further
reflect when the report comes on the 2nd
of november so thank you
councillor edmond
uh thank you mr mayor i've read all the
submissions and i found them quite
interesting they had different points
we have a full spectrum of opinion from
electing councillors at large over the
whole area
and
in some ways
that's
not a bad system
two
as what our submission has presented
today perhaps having counsellors more
geographically based within their own
local communities so there is a big
spectrum there there is no perfect
solution
to what we're suggesting and i feel as
previous speakers have indicated that
the present system is serving us as well
as it can
it's not perfect but
i personally
support the current system
i think in terms of the
kaiapoi would end ward
but the population growth as mentioned
earlier
with ravenswood in particular
will balance those matters out
and at the end of the day i think people
elect the counsellor that they think is
going to serve them best
rather than
and i'm in the
unusual position of not living in a
particular ward so you could say i'm
independent
in that sense but um i think everyone
tries to connect with their communities
and community boards
and whilst it's not perfect i think the
current system is working reasonably
well and i'm supportive of it
thank you
thank you for the speakers council duty
thank you very much yes i will um
occur with the next um one
for the for three years only i do feel
that we do need to the next new
councillors do need to really consider
the um the number of people that are
moving into the area and you've got that
large influx down down the wooden area
excuse me
but also rightly
excuse me um down the hoka mandel area
that is starting to develop and grow
more as well
so i think in three years time and
we you need to have a really serious
look at
where your where your um where your
areas lie and and
re-re-jug your awards accordingly
okay fear the speakers
write a reply
uh wait for you to get there
write reply counselor williams
okay so i'll put the recommendation all
those in favor please say aye
contrary
to clear that carried
thank you
that brings us to the end of
business
so
at this point i'll declare um the
hearing um concluded so
and we've got a briefing
which is due to start at 2 30. we could
possibly
see if we could bring that forward